that's continuing that upward trend that
we've seen
sharply now climbing since the end of
october the state has seen more than
112 thousand cases now since the
pandemic began at the end of february
this is what's happening in clark county
we remain flagged of the elevated
transmission
list right now the elevated transmission
disease list is what it's called
we're on that now for the fourth week
we're reporting 869 new cases in today's
case update however just five deaths one
too many though
totaling 90 thousand cases in clark
county
the recovery rate is at 88.2 percent
right now
hospitalizations from coronavirus are
close to record highs here in the u.s
cases on the rise in nevada and 45
other states and experts warn the worst
is yet to come
more than one million americans now
testing positive for coronavirus over
the last 10 days
making this the worst stretch of
infections so far
nearly half of those cases are in the
midwest but we have some good news to
tell you
on treatment the fda has given emergency
approval to eli
lilly for the first antibody treatment
for covid patients who have mild to
moderate symptoms
it works by attaching a risk and
blocking its entry
into cells and also possibly by helping
the person's immune system clear the
virus
the data we have suggests that early
treatment may help people avoid disease
progression
and avoid hospitalization right now
safety testing for this new antibody
drug is ongoing and the government will
start distributing 300 000 doses of this
tomorrow
[Music]
well today is the last day that the
clark county
is going to be accepting mail-in votes
as long as they're postmarked by
november 3rd now they only received
seven more ballots today so it's really
just slowly trickling in the county has
until the end of thursday to count
all of the votes clark county election
chief joe gloria says that means people
who need to verify their signatures
which is called a signature cure we'll
have to do that by five o'clock on
thursday as well
it'll be very late at night when we're
done because the deadline
is at five o'clock and so there'll be a
mad rush to make sure that anybody that
has cured by five o'clock we've got to
go pull those ballots we've got to make
sure
that they get sent to the county board
gloria also said there's a lot of
misinformation going on to the general
public right now and they should be very
careful
about anything that does not come from
the secretary of state's office meantime
here we are now a week after election
day and the results are still
being counted in some of the most
watched local races so let's take a look
at those now
one of those includes this very hotly
contested race this is for senate seat
district six between democratic senator
majority leader
nicole cannizzaro now leading republican
challenger april becker
also in senate district five that race
remaining very tight
democrat christie watson increasing her
lead now over republican carrie and buck
and the clark county commission this
one's gone back and forth but democrat
ross miller
now maintaining his slight lead over
current las vegas city council member
stavros anthony and also very close is a
ballot question one now you might recall
this one would remove the board of
regents
from the nevada constitution at this
point 50 50 percent this one is really
just too close to call very tight there
while president-elect joe biden
continues to lay out plans for his
upcoming administration
despite ongoing challenges from
president trump and his supporters over
the election results
natalie brand reports now from
wilmington delaware
president-elect joe biden discussed the
affordable care act after the u.s
supreme court heard arguments on the
constitutionality of the landmark health
care law
come january we're going to work quickly
with the congress to dramatically ramp
up health care protections
is it time to concede on capitol hill
vice president mike pence attended a
closed meeting with senate republicans
where lawmakers expressed support for
president trump's challenges to the
election results
until the electoral college votes
anyone who's running for office can
exhaust
concerns the president continues to make
unsubstantiated claims of voter fraud
and ballot counting abuse
meanwhile lawmakers are reacting to a
memo issued by attorney general bill
barr
this week telling prosecutors they can
pursue substantial allegations of voting
irregularities before the election is
certified
i thought it was perfectly appropriate
what he did yesterday is
unprecedented and unforgivable here in
delaware president-elect biden says the
transition continues and they have
enough resources even if the general
services administration continues to
block the process
have you tried to reach out at all to
the president and if he is watching
right now
what would you say to him mr president
look forward to speaking with you
there will be a smooth transition to a
second trump administration
secretary pompeo says the world should
have every confidence that the state
department is functional and successful
with the president who's in office on
january 20.
senior administration officials tell cbs
news there are still no plans to
consider
inviting biden to the white house until
after all legal options are exhausted
natalie brand cbs news wilmington
delaware and today president-elect biden
spoke by phone with leaders of the
united kingdom
ireland france and germany we want to
remind you to stay with 8 news now your
local election headquarters you're going
to find the latest updates both on air
and online of course
also eight newsnow dot com denise
other news here at four clock a mother
accused of killing her two young
children appeared in court this morning
clark county prosecutors say that 26
year old amanda sharp jefferson
drowned her victims then denied even
knowing them that she was even their
mother
bianca holman is following the case
amanda sharp jefferson is facing two
counts of murder in the death of her
one-year-old
rose singleton and her two-month-old
lilly singleton
according to an arrest report jefferson
told the children's father
she drowned them both girls were
discovered by their father jaequan
singleton
singleton told police she was acting
strange a few weeks earlier but seemed
fine when he saw her the evening prior
police say sharp jefferson denied having
any children and said someone must have
put them
in her apartment at first sharp
jefferson was not in the courtroom
her lawyer claimed that there was
concerns about the reaction to the
allegations
she eventually appeared and said she
understood the charges
and also understood the next date for
her scheduled preliminary hearing
i do not find that the
concerns expressed at least at this
juncture
would outraid the public's right to at
least
view electronically the arraignment
sharp jefferson's lawyer also filed two
motions the first is to preserve
evidence the second regarding bail sharp
jefferson will return to court on
november
24th reporting from the regional justice
center bianca holman 8 news now
and the search continues for a suspect
in a shooting last month now metro
police need your help
they say this happened back on the 30th
of october at an apartment complex near
las vegas boulevard and nellis
investigators say the victim was
sitting in a car when apparently this
man shot him the victim though
is expected to survive but police also
want to talk to these three women you're
seeing here in these images who were
seen with the suspect
just before the shooting if you have any
information please call crime stoppers
right it is 407 on this tuesday
afternoon we're talking cold
temperatures this morning ted i got to
tell you that today was the first day of
putting on those seat warmers in the car
i did too right you know it feels really
nice especially when you're driving they
were saying yeah you're going to use
them out here well yeah you gotta use
them you gotta use them because it gets
chilly out here
yeah some of the coldest temperatures
this season david in fact last time we
saw
temperatures down in the low 40s was
actually
last month however we beat that this
morning
at 38 degrees this morning last time we
saw that temperature
was february 3rd that's how long it's
been both the conditions have been the
same clear skies that allow the
temperatures
to drop even more to those low 30s when
you have calm winds light winds
that allows temperatures to drop rapidly
temps right now in the mid 50s 54 for
henderson las vegas 56 along with north
las vegas however
this is where we should be at this time
of the year 70 even
and of course we are way below that
probably not going to see that number
until we start to get
to the weekend satellite radar clear
skies here some snow showers up in salt
lake from the wasatch
and the bitterroots but we remain dry at
least for now do we have another shot
of showers it's possible we'll show it
to you coming up in your most active
forecast
straight ahead looking forward to that
ted thank you well there's a new and
improved playground in the southeast
part of the valley to tell you about
this afternoon the department of parks
and recreation hosting a grand opening
ceremony for the new area at sunset park
that's right at eastern in sunset let's
take a live look at those festivities
right now great time to get out and
enjoy
they tell us the biggest challenges
include the biggest changes that is
include adding a new steel shade
structure the playground equipment was
replaced to update its features
to today's safety standards great to see
all the kiddos out there on a tuesday
afternoon while the henderson silver
knights
have a home to call their very own
sports director chris matthews joining
us now with today's grand opening of
lifeguard arena chris
thank you donation speaking of kiddos
there'll be a lot of kiddos inside this
one right here yeah first and uh
you had the city national now you have
two sheets of ice now in the south end
of the valley two more
in henderson one of the goals of knights
owner bill foley was when he bought this
club
let's bring youth hockey to the valley
that's what he's certainly doing making
good on those promises that he made
of course and he's making good on his
word to build
winners and how about this the kids will
really enjoy this they'll learn hockey
they'll continue to skate
and enjoy the sport of hockey that's
what he's doing today was a grand
opening in the lifeguard arena it's
similar in every way to city national
out there in summerlin fact truth be
told the henderson facility
might be a little nicer now hey they
learned how to make it better right and
the knights have accomplished that goal
with the grand opening today obviously
for the guys it's good for the travel
aspect that you mentioned and
you know for the organization to keep a
closer eye on their uh their young guys
and how they're doing how they're
progressing how they're developing
that sort of stuff and obviously again
like you said it's it's nice for those
guys who
you know do go back and forth a little
bit where they can just make a drive up
2 15 and that's all they have to do they
don't have to fly anywhere so that's
that's
i think a big thing for the guys as well
all right the team yesterday revealed
the jerseys for the silver knights and
now they're available to purchase
outside well inside the livery we should
say
oh this will be the home to the silver
knights so the silver knights will
practice at lifeguard arena and for the
first two years they play at the orleans
arena
their season is scheduled to begin in
february david
just right around the corner all right
chris thanks we are just getting started
right here on eight news now at four
o'clock
coming up a new website could help your
kids with learning at home it's the new
resource being called
the netflix of school plus
apple unveils a new computer with a
brand new brain
i'm nancy chen with a look at the latest
computers now that americans are relying
on them more
than ever
[Music]
prestige chrysler jeep dodge
you're watching eight news now live at
four
apple held its third product event in
three months and this time the tech
giant is revealing a new line of
machines
as americans are depending more and more
on personal computers
than they ever have nancy chen reports
but there is just one more thing
apple ceo tim cook's one more thing is
the tech company's latest line of
personal computers
all coming with a new brain m1
the m1 chip is made by apple and
replaces the processors from intel
inside previous macs the company claims
the m1
makes its macbooks much faster macbook
air is faster
than 98 percent of pc laptops sold in
the last year
in the macbook pro there is the promise
of sharper graphics
and up to 20 hours of battery life and
with this combination
of performance and awesome battery life
the productivity of our pro
users goes through the roof apple's
announcement comes as computer purchases
are
surging max sales jumped nearly 30
percent in the last quarter
you're at a point where every single
person in your household basically needs
their own computer of some type now
cnet's dan ackerman says with people
working and
students learning at home all the tech
companies are offering a range of
options for the holidays
the microsoft surface has a touch screen
many laptops double as a tablet
and lenovo's thinkpad can even fold plus
there are plenty of google powered
chromebooks
which can be very inexpensive 300 350
you can get a perfectly good 13 or 15
inch chromebook they usually have touch
screens on them which is great because
kids are used to everything having a
touch screen
the new macbook air starts at 9.99 the
macbook pro is 12.99
and both are available to order right
now nancy chen
cbs news new york adding it to my list
while students all over the country
maybe even in your house
are still struggling with online classes
but one high school senior is hoping to
make this school year just a little bit
easier
i remember thinking that you know the
school systems must have great lists of
recommended resources for online
learning
and i was wrong i was binge watching
netflix while doing school of course
and i did some research on netflix and i
saw that they personalized their
recommendations based on more than
75 000 categories if we could take that
level
of personalization and technology to
online learning
it could truly transform the world that
is sophia jaffe this summer she launched
her own website it's
elearn.fyi it's a collection of more
than 300 online resources
everything from coding and museum tours
to foreign languages
14 year old liam dancy recently started
using the site to help him with some
math and he says
it's made all the difference i have a
lot more questions it's hard to
understand things like through a
computer screen but with these websites
i can ask the questions
at any time i want really and i get and
i get the answers and i
succeed and i learn and understand
things
the free site has attracted visitors
from the united states
and more than 100 other countries
all right as we talked about as on the
top of the newscast it was cold today
ted are these chilly temps going to
stick around or did i move to the wrong
place
i think i think when you came from maine
i did come from maine and i thought you
know it's going to be 70 degrees all
year long
but not this morning but it was just
kind of a welcome party for you right
okay
i'll take it like that next week david
you're going to love the temperatures
next week all right let's
get to the rain gauge shall we trace of
rain this weekend that was it that's all
we got all right so that record streak
continues
at 204 days actually because today we
obviously are not going to see any rain
so for the month the trace of rain we
should be a tenth of an inch so we are
way behind as far as
precip goes and of course we all know
that's right because uh we haven't had
that measurable rain since april it has
been that long all right let's get to
our temperatures right now sky canyon at
54 degrees
same goes for centennial hills of
providence 53 for aleante
60 for sunrise mountain with 58 for
whitney ranch
henderson coming in right now at double
fives mountains edge of 56 along with
rhodes ranch and southern highlands in
anthem and seven hills
currently at 52 elsewhere 58 for prop 54
boulder city
got a lot of viewers in laflin 63 for
you nice and mild the same goes
for death valley doppler network again
dry conditions i just don't see
any echoes coming back on the radar at
least for the next few days here but
that could change
by the time we get to friday which we'll
talk about in
just a bit temperature trend though
however each day gets warmer these are
your daytime highs now so of course
this is where we are we should be all
right between 69 to 67 degrees
and notice each day slowly gets warmer
we finally get near average by the time
we get to the end of week on sunday
and look at next week the 70's return
monday and tuesday so here's your
forecast 38 degrees overnight mostly
clear
and cold again light winds so we'll
match the temperature we saw this
morning officially
we know how chilly that was veteran's
day for tomorrow looking good 59 degrees
but still
cool because we should be at 69 so we're
still some 10 degrees below normal
winds stay light neighborhood by
neighbor temperatures here you go this
time we start off in the northwest part
of the valley
attendee hills at 57 along with sky
canyon
summer at 56 mountain zed you'll be at
58 degrees along with north las vegas
sunrise mountain 62 green valley 61
saint rose parkway
seven hills anthem 56 henderson coming
in at 57 degrees
outside of town we got you covered here
you go proper 54 for tomorrow
cold up in lee canyon 34 degrees above
the freezing mark mesquite 57
laflin come in mid 60's in death valley
at 67 degrees so here's a look at your
seven-day forecast looking ahead now
we'll see increased cloud cover tomorrow
in the afternoon we'll see those clouds
also on thursday
notice your numbers go up like we talked
about the overnight lows will improve a
little bit but we're still staying on
the chilly side
breezy by friday some models will hit to
get the chance of some
showers we think that will stay north of
us mainly and
maybe some mountain snow showers but
it's only a slight chance
and then we get through the rest of the
week it's going to be a great weekend
look at that
mid to high 60s big change from last
weekend we had all that rain and snow
and then back to the 70s just in time
for david charns to enjoy those
70s to return denise we'll send it back
to you he is not alone
all right ted thanks well coming up
after the break here all new at four
o'clock
it's an early christmas for one family
where you can catch this friendly
competition between father and son
and what looks like an incredible toy
store is actually also an
ice cream shop and the best place to
celebrate national sunday day tomorrow
so i'll tell you where we are
coming up
[Music]
electric not a bad apple in the bunch
you're watching 8 news now live at 4.
so no matter what time of year it is ice
cream is always the perfect way to treat
yourself
and your family tomorrow is national
sunday day it's wednesday but hey we can
eat whenever we want rocky is live for
us at sloane's ice cream giving us a
head start to where to celebrate hey
rocky
hey david okay so because sloane's is
top 10
ice cream shops in the u.s okay first
and foremost but also you guys
should come celebrate here because it's
a toy store too so david i want to let
you know i brought you something
this is for you because you are a boss
so i'll bring this to you
after after the show here um but let's
get into the ice cream okay because
we'll show you
all the rest of the shop in a second the
ice cream here is unique
it's not your basic sundae right america
so you're going to have
different type of flavors we have
different types of chocolate vanillas
and all of that
uh-huh the thing is it's going to be
high-quality ice cream that means
sixteen percent more body fat and it's
gonna have fifty percent less air
okay it's a little bit more rich and
then some flavor and they also taste
homemade right that's something really
special about you guys any flavor see
we do batch by batch and we would not do
like a whole machine to do a lot i love
that so the good thing about this that
you will have unique flavors like curry
cake
okay vanilla cream cheese ice cream
uh-huh and we blend in the carrot cake
in it
okay um cookie monster will be next to
it it will be homemade chocolate chip
cookies for oreo that will be my cookies
and cream
amazing and then i have like fresh
strawberry
i have circus it will be cotton candy
gummy bears like apple pie
oh my gosh vanilla ice cream everything
that you could imagine this is what i
call
or what you've been called uh ice cream
utopia and that is
that couldn't be more accurate so since
we have a plethora of flavors here also
for your dogs by the way
yeah homemade treats for your dog so
just in case you guys are watching who
has dogs
at home okay so we have some flavors
here i'm gonna go ahead and choose one
to taste
so over here i'm gonna don't tell me
don't tell me don't tell me
oh shoot that's okay okay i can't do
that one so i'm gonna go with this blue
flavor oh my god
all right you guys ready yeah all right
what is this
blue ice cream
[Music]
cotton candy yes it is this is delicious
i don't actually usually like cotton
candy but that is good
okay so on top of just the ice cream
you can get your sundaes okay
because tomorrow is national sunday day
please describe this
beautiful creation we're gonna have five
scoops of ice cream of your choice
okay so we do provide samples you can so
you can make that
and then you're going to have fresh
cookie in it we have m m cookies or
peanut butter cookies
it has three wet toppings hot fudge hot
cream white one is in it
oh my god oh shoot dry toppings with
your whipped cream and your decoration
can you so i got to bring this back to
the station somehow before it goes but
you gotta eat it with the with the
shovel that's how big it is okay so
coming up later in the show i'm gonna
show you what the kitchen sink sunday
means
i'm a little scared i'm a little scared
i'll send it back to you guys you're
going to need a wheelbarrow to take out
that kitchen sink ice cream whatever
that's going to look like all right
we'll see in the next half hour
so as we gear up for the holidays the
las vegas rescue mission is hosting a
turkey giveaway
this is really for families in need it's
going to be happening this thursday and
saturday 2500 turkeys are going to be
given out
but this will be a first come first
serve basis from 8 to noon
this is a drive-through event so the
turkey bags are going to be placed
directly in the trunk
at the las vegas rescue mission all
right so a father and son in new mexico
are really taking their christmas
displays to a whole new level
to have the relationship that we have
with the christmas lights makes me
really happy and makes them really happy
it's always been a family tradition for
tim and dallas seawort to put up a
holiday lights
in november and it's really continued
even as the pair now lives apart
by about five minute drive no surprise
they still get a little bit competitive
i had mine up and i thought i was going
to and then he had to go in one up me
and
make all the lights flash so i think he
has me this year my son might have beat
me putting up the christmas lights but i
out did him by getting something
different
uh well you know what dad made one this
year but it's a relationship between
father and son that's shining even
brighter and dallas admits hey i helped
my dad out
with his display david what was the
movie was it the griswolds where they
went crazy on the christmas tree
he uh he shocked the electric grid
that's what this is i really like those
santas that rock back and forth
all right after the break all new at 4
30. have you gotten out to eat amid the
covid pandemic coming up next we're
taking a closer look at which safety
measures to look for
when you're picking a place to eat
the fate of the affordable care act
hangs in the balance and basil drum
reporting in washington
how this supreme court case could bring
about change to health coverage
more lawyer less fee
[Music]
now live you're watching eight news now
live at four good afternoon the fate of
the affordable care act hangs in the
balance thanks for joining us here at 4
30. i'm denise valdez and i'm david
charns kirsten is off right now the
supreme court is weighing arguments
heard earlier today about the affordable
care act
you may know it as obamacare washington
correspondent basil john reports on what
lawmakers are saying about whether the
aca will stand or not
after hearing arguments on both sides
the fate of the affordable care act now
rests in the hands of the supreme court
the argument this morning in the in the
supreme court is one that's
deeply troubling to me virginia senator
tim kaine says republicans and president
trump
have made it their mission to end the
aca and he set his side on it is sort of
like captain ahab trying to hunt moby
deck
from the first day of his presidency why
the
party's top priority should be taking
health insurance away from so many with
no plans to replace it is beyond me
pennsylvania congressman fred keller
says there is a reason to go after the
aca
what we need to do with health care in
the united states we need to create
competition
we need to have transparency and
that and allow people to have choice
keller says whether or not the aca
is struck down congress needs to
reevaluate the country's health care
system
let's stop talking about coverage and
let's talk about delivery of
affordable care because all we heard
about for so many years is how many
people are going to be covered
that we're currently covered kane says
the health crisis
brought on by the pandemic showcases
just how necessary the aca
is millions and millions have been able
to get through this pandemic better
because of the aca
this administration has pursued a
one-way path to reducing coverage and we
don't need to
keep going down that path a decision on
the case is not expected
until june reporting in washington i'm
basil john
we are expecting an update from the
governor in about 90 minutes at six
o'clock let's take a look at coronavirus
cases here in nevada more than
1300 positive cases that is new today
the test positivity rate from those
cases
also increasing we're about 13 percent
now
nevada has seen more than 112 thousand
positive cases
since the pandemic began seven more
deaths
reported today let's take a look now at
clark county
about 860 new positive cases here
five more deaths and cases are up to
more than 90 thousand
since the pandemic began clark county
and the southern nevada health district
offering free covet testing this week
the info right there on your screen
the walk-in site will be at the gym at
cheyenne high school thursday and friday
from 8 in the morning until
noon now you don't need to make an
appointment but this is first come first
serve
and if you do go you have to wear a mask
and bring a photo id
well after months of distance education
the clark county school district now has
a plan to get students back
into the classroom it's a hybrid model
combining learning at home and in person
now if it passes employees would return
to work as soon as december 1st
it proposes capping classroom size at 50
percent
then on january 4th a mix of in-person
and at-home learning would start for
students who are
in certain grades then on january 11th
all
other grades would start students would
be divided into different groups for
either hybrid learning or full-time
distance education
now not everybody though is on board
with this proposal
nothing really beats face-to-face
learning and being in the same room as
the person you're learning from
as a kindergarten teacher i am not
comfortable with that just because i
know
especially when we're talking about
primary there's no way that they're
going to be able to adhere
to the social distancing guidelines mask
wearing and extra sanitation measures
would also be required
the proposal even provides visual aids
on how to space out deaths to comply
with social distancing
no playground equipment water fountains
or field trips would be allowed
the board of trustees is set to review
this plan at their meeting this thursday
and they
could vote to approve it or maybe
postpone it we're going to have much
more on this
for you coming up tonight at 6. on this
week's travel tuesday what should you
think about when deciding where to eat
out
wendy gillette takes a look at safety
measures restaurants are taking right
now
and how you can check out what
precautions those restaurants are taking
[Music]
restaurants are adapting to respond to
changing coronavirus rules and safety
measures
so are customers mainly what i look for
is just outdoor seating
making sure the tables are kind of
spaced out a little bit larry lynch is
the senior vice president of science and
industry at the national restaurant
association
the group produced this guide to help
restaurants operate safely
when i'm looking at choosing a
restaurant what should i look for
what you want to see them doing is first
and foremost separating tables and
chairs
making sure that there is a distance
between you and any other guests
preferably there's no waiting area look
at what they're doing for cleaning and
sanitizing
are they wiping down tables lynn says
you should also make sure
staff members are wearing face coverings
because they'll likely be less than six
feet away from you
and all the other customers because
people want more information about how
restaurants are adjusting
the online site yelp has added a covid19
section to list health and safety
measures
on each restaurant's page the company
also recently allowed users to verify
what restaurants are doing akil ramesh
is the head of consumer products it's
clear that consumers have this need to
feel safe as they consider going back to
businesses
lynch says before you head out head
online
do research and check a restaurant's web
page to see if it lists its kovid 19
safety precautions
if it doesn't don't be afraid to call as
a consumer
you certainly have the right and
probably right now a little bit more
even the responsibility to ask the
question
as for where to sit lynch says outside
is always better than
inside to lessen potential exposure look
for a restaurant with good air flow
these days a nice breeze is much more
than just a pleasant pairing with your
meal
wendy gillette cbs news new york and the
national restaurant association
recommends restaurants provide hand
sanitizer if you go there so that's
something you want to look out for when
you go out to eat denise
well a preliminary report on a deadly
plane crash in las vegas confirms the
pilot said his engine was indeed out
the crash happened on the 29th about
four miles outside of the henderson
airport
the two people on board were killed the
pilot left the north las vegas airport
he was headed to san diego but crashed
while trying to make that emergency
landing
federal crash investigators released
this preliminary report
but it could take as long as a year for
a final report to eventually be
released and a buddhist group's lawsuit
could throw a wrench into the sale of
the las vegas monorail to the lbcva
the tourism agency is in the process of
buying the bankrupt monorail for 24
million dollars
but the world buddhism association
headquarters says the monorail would be
selling land that does not belong to
them
the group bought the property at saharan
paradise to build
a temple they have not started
construction though
the buddhists filed the objection in the
monorails bankruptcy case
all right so we're getting uh well it's
been unseasonably cooler for us
at least it just went like that but now
it's going to kind of go back up again
ted welcome to las vegas
all right welcome to the desert right
and and to
pair ourselves with that colder weather
look at downtown summerlin
getting it oh they got their skating
rink skating regret look at these fellas
right here just kind of deciding okay
what do we throw on here throw ice on
there or what right
so yeah this is a great place to skate
i'm glad to see that they're going to be
doing this again
because of course this is a big spot for
everybody to uh
to go skating uh during the winter
months and of course during christmas
of course social distancing of course
air quality wanna watch that because of
course we've been seeing that smoke
seep to our areas these past few months
but not the case now
and the reason for that is we actually
had some rain in california ozone carbon
dust and smoke look at that in the good
category range
no problems as far as air quality goes
current conditions outside how about
those numbers 56 degrees at this hour
winds staying light that's good right
then we head down to henderson
54 degrees winds also nice and calm
there
we're actually right where we were
yesterday at this time right around the
mid 50s it looks like it remained that
way
through this evening too in those 40s
again so a nice chilly evening for
tonight
we'll add a little bit of cloud cover
and those winds turn calm tomorrow
morning too we'll have a final look at
your forecast
coming up in just a few minutes david
over to you all right looking like
winner ted thank you 8 news now is
honoring those who put their lives on
the line for the safety of ours
of course tomorrow is veterans day join
us for the veterans voices special that
is at
3 30 we'll hear from veterans as well as
organizations
who help soldiers transition back to
civilian life again
tomorrow afternoon right here on channel
8 at 3
30. and as we observe veterans day
tomorrow around the valley there will be
plenty of deals offered for our veterans
and any active military from retail to
restaurants
local businesses are hoping to help you
and your families
celebrate with some special freebies and
discounts we have a full list of those
deals you see them there on our website
of course
8newsnow.com it's a long list too well
coming up next here on the valley's news
leader we are getting ready for the
premiere of swatch right here on channel
8.
we will have an exclusive look at the
return of the prime time drama
and what you can expect this season
and we are at sloane's ice cream in the
venetian where it is a utopia of ice
cream and toys
how you can eat an ice cream sundae
tomorrow for national sunday day that's
big at the kitchen sink
what that means coming up
sunny sky
electric not a bad apple in the bunch
you're watching eight news now five to
four
well tomorrow is national sunday day and
to celebrate why not have the ice cream
sundae of your dreams
rocky theatres is live at sloanes in the
venetian to show us where ice cream
fantasies become reality hey if they've
got a unicorn then they've got an ice
cream fantasy
actually denise that's perfect because
i'm carrying this cutie pie for you i
figured
if i was gonna pick anything it would be
the unicorn because you are a unicorn
okay there we go all right let's talk
about ice cream now okay you said all of
our ice cream fantasies and i
have a feeling that um this could
suffice yeah
only get a little closer this is called
the kitchen sink america tell us all
about it
so you're going to have 18s too four of
our 18 scoops of ice cream oh my god
for brownies for two kids and all my top
it's a dry topping sweet topping so
you're gonna have marshmallows
m m chocolate peanuts everything is
gonna be in there
oh my gosh okay so when people come for
example tomorrow for national sunday day
how do they order this how do they eat
it because like this is not something
you can just
walk through the venetian with don't
take home yeah so we're gonna have it
ready for you guys and tell me the
flavors we're gonna make it for you
uh-huh we obviously you get your spoon
right the only
deal here is that you cannot take this
thing home of course okay
you can have it as long as you want you
can experience how long you want
it so just make sure you're ready to eat
ice cream yeah you're ready for all the
chocolate
and just dig in oh my gosh this is
amazing i wish that i could bring this
back to the station because i know some
of your
mouths are salivating but let's talk
about everything else you guys have here
obviously this is the kitchen sink we
showed you
the sandcastle's gonna be the sand
castle sundae what other sundays can
they get tomorrow
so we have us more sundays we have a
luxury sample
that will be nine small scoops so you
can if you don't know what ice cream go
with yeah you can go with that sampler
so that's a good idea here our cookie
wish it will be two of our
big cookies in it how did i make a mess
i'm not even eating
that's a good sunday when you know
you're making a mess all right and then
it will be two of the big cookies with
ice cream mayonnaise we
found that for you guys all right
classic sundae if you want to go a
little bit basic
and okay good and i don't you know i
don't even know if you can say basic in
here okay because this is just
not your basic ice cream shop and i want
to tell you guys about this
apple pie ice cream okay on the menu you
guys when i
bit into this there was a whole apple
in it okay so they've actually make the
apple pies
and then put them in the ice cream
yourselves so what we do we have to bake
the pie so we caramelize the apples we
put in wow
we bake that for you guys and then we
blend it in on our vanilla cinnamon
incredible i love it here can i stay
and oh so i brought denise the unicorn i
brought david the count because he's a
boss
yeah what do i get for ted one more
little thing okay
so far zuka get it get it
happy national sunday day tomorrow come
celebrate oh
by the way veterans eat ice cream free
tomorrow yes so come on down